قال حاكم مقاطعه دونياسك الاوكراني ان
سبعه اشخاص قتلوا وجرح عشرات في قصف روسي
استهدف معظم مدن وبلدات اقليم دوباس وقالت
قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه ان القتال تجدد
في جبهه باخموت وان قواتها تحافظ على
بواقعها وتعزز خطوطها الدفاعيه عبر ارسال
تعزيزات العسكريه للمدينه
اعلن مركز الدفاع الاقليميه التابعه
لسلطات الدنيا اشكال الموالياه لروسيا
اصابه ثلاثه مدنيين في قصر الاوكراني على
احياء سكنيه بالمدينه واضاف المركز ان
القوات الاخرانيه استهدفت بالقضاء في
المدفعيه والصاروخيه اربع مناطق سكنيه ما
اسفر عن تضرر بعض المنشات البنيه التحتيه
ومنازل سكنيه بها واشار المركز الى ان
القصف طال ايضا الاحياء الشماليه والغربيه
من دونياتك وبلده شخصيه
وبلدات قريبه من خط القتال بين الجانبين